Hello everybody my name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to DOOM!
I was exploring around and I found this cool dude... who seems to have been impaled!
He doesn't look too good -- he looks like Alexander from Amnesia the Dark Descent.
Anyway, I uh, just picked up some ammo here and I have recovered! ...from my ordeal yesterday!
Uh, the ordeal being thirteen Habanero peppers, but I AM better now, and everything is going much smoother
so let's carry on with this game and everything is gonna be hunky-dory.
No I'm not going into details because I don't need to do that.
Cyber-Mancubus, ok , the work of Dr. Pierce and her biogeneticists. OH!, So these armored fellows, OHHH!
Now here I thought they were from hell but I didn't realize the extent of Dr. Pierce's research.
So she...
[breathes]
Had something very much to do with it.
Here's another heart just sitting on a pedestal.
Why are you there?!
I have a funny feeling you were from the original Doom somehow but I'm missing a point here.
Oh no!
Ist undt trap!
Again with the traps!
You'd think that they would learn that traps don't exactly work on me.
Cause I seem to be a little bit more resilient than they give me credit for.
But you know,
I don't give them a lot of credit either they're kinda just a bunch of stupid demons.
Hi!
How's it going?
Yes I can hit you out of the air.
OH NOO!
Hang on. Come on hit-hit-hit the damn explodey barrel dammit.
Alright...
Hang on this guy needs some more "sass in his ass"
Oh no. He assploded.
Oh I guess he's dead now.
Okay no one else to play with.
Anybody...
Oooh story time!
I don't have any water this time I forgot to get some.
[Mark strokes his beard]
[Mark touches his mustache]
[Mark looks at the viewers and taps his mustache]
[Mark is now in the "What?" phase]
[Mark is now touching his lips]
[Mark tips his head slightly sideways]
[Mark tries to process on what is going on in the story]
[Back to the "What?" phase]
Wait? So that...
That introduces another character. I thought they were going to keep jerking me off for a little bit
about how great I was.
But that tells something about someone else that helped me?
And gave me my armor?
So this Wretch, Maybe I was pulled from the wrong timeline
and then they gave me this armor which
made me even stronger so that means
that I killed-I killed some people
without this armor, which just goes to show how badass I am
but that's interesting... huh
I don't know, am I even human is a good question
huh, oh well.  Nothing to be said about that
That says I need to go over that way, but I can't
stheem to fit through the door
so maybe there was a uh - was there like a skull button
that I missed over here because I'm very stupid about these sort of things?
NOOOO
it's a whole lot of nothing - FUCK OFF!
alright what do we got?
what? There's something over there.
it says there's something over down there
Ahhh...
what do we got? oh
uh huh, no? what damn it
oh no that must be where the switch
for the uh secret DOOM level is
but I don't know where there would be a switch
eh I see, I'm supposed to go in here
with the river and blood and (gibberish)
never mind, I can't talk, but I know it's a trap
huah!
ah damn you, Pinky, damn you, you Pinky bastard
you invisi-Pinky
don't do that, thank you, alright
uh oh, it sounds like there's something behind me
no? no one? I was expecting friends
and a party maybe and I'm on the lookout for
oh there we go, that's what I was missing
I was waiting for you
alright, just-just don't
just don't, just don't, don't, don't
man, they just shower blood, don't they? eugh
I mean I am shooting explosives and
about a million bullets into them, so
I'm assuming there is going to be some sort of a shower
what is in there? oooh secret secrets?
maybe not...maybe not at all...
okay, alright then
I'M OFF, I'm off to school
have a good day! what's that? why is that there?
What'd that do? That open up something down here maybe?
OH HEY, wha--how you doin? Welcome!
Man, how many-how many of you did Dr. Pierce experiment on?
seems almost unfair.
Well, I mean, not unfair, obviously I'm still going to kill them dead no matter what they do
and no matter who they talk to
but that's not going to stop me from feeling bad for them.
Oh no! nah, that'd be a waste, eh
Eh.
ah geez, what a wimp! Two plasma bullets *blows raspberries*
Hey you, stop that
I don't want to get that haste just yet, I want to wait for something else.
I actually don't take damage from these anymore, I forgot, whoops
That's--Stop playing soccer with my explosive barrels.
Alright...
There was some sort of an achievement for, yeah
Kill 10 demons with explosive barrels, ooookay.
Boink! Is anybody going to present me a challenge?
How bout you? no
Nope? okay bye
uh huh, there you go
oooh more Cacodemons, looks like it's Cacodemon central over here
Ohp, oh hey, blam
man, that-that heat blast really does a number on these guys
whoop. Oh, where'd he go? There ya are.
Uh-huh.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, I'll get the haste, fine.
whoa, whoa, hey whoa
Can't get me, Pinky, I'm too quick for ya now.
Oh you're dead. Never mind, I was shooting your corpse. No point for that.
Sorry, I missed ya
Oh no, I'm back to slow old me again.
alright then
Oh hey! Can you not? It'd be great if you didn't
Thank you! Man, I didn't know that just that was all I needed
You know, it seem like these Mancubuses have - or is? that's not a Mancubus
Was that a Mancubus? I can't remember. That's a Mancubus, yeah
Seems like the Mancubus already have some sort of advanced armor
You know, I mean a lot of these guys just take
ooooh! I know what you are! I was looking for you
because I realized that there was already a secret entrance already over there
just past the way, whoa.
Okay thank you, for that.
It's convenient. I'm going to get the map first though. Thank you!
Okay, so I got the auto map, but over here - man I am not taking any more damage.
Yes, right here. Ooooh I remember this, this was in the last episode of the campaign.
Ohh this was soooo cool
I never knew what these were, they were just like
stone carvings of this one dude, I could never tell
if he just had a really thick neck or like sideburns that extended a little bit too far.
eh who knows? We will never know
alright, but anyway, back to the fray
I've got to get this yellow key and then find where the yellow key goes cause I don't know
Where is all this blood coming from?! Why is it flowing out of Argent energy?
Is that the secret to it? Argent energy is actually just the power of death being funneled
ah that seems like something that would be possible
huh, should I go through there?
There was a yellow door back that way
but I can't get to it, okay
So I must continue forward
Ahhh goot, I am back at the beginning.
So what do I do up here?
Anybody gonna tell me? Why do I have two wayp-- oooh that would be handy
Okay, but I could also go through there but let me go through here first
boink!
Prolly gonna help me reclaim the whatever-the-hell I'm trying to get
I know I got low ammo
oooo fancy!
ooh that's not what I was thinking it was going to be
ahhh
What a juxtaposition to my technology. Old stone gear works.
Alright then, what did that do? Is there going to be blood that's shootin out of everywhere now?
no? Okay I'm off
to unlock the other lock and get this undone
oooh pretty, big arena, I like it
you wanna fight me? thank you, I was getting lonely a little bit
*makes shooting noises with mouth*
don't do that
there was no point
there's no point in resisting
I think there's a quad damage that's under lockdown over there I don't know how they're...
I don't know how they think they're going to hide it from me
I mean, there's no point in hiding it because I'm gonna miss it anyway
because that's how I always function
as a player, as a gamer
I just know never what's two feet in front of my god damn face
hi buddy, I hope that hit you. It didn't, did it? Damn it.
Oh it did hit you, it did. Hello, thank you!
Oh man, that's gross, why would I want to shove my hand inside that thing anyway
seems like something detrimental to my experience
Eh.
Bldldlm
Uh-huh.
Man, what a bunch of pathetic losers
All in a room by themselves, not really doing anything for anybody
They just come here to die over and over again. So sad for them.
DON'T EVEN TRY IT! Ow you gave me a little bit of ouchies
You scruffed my armor, how dare you?
I was trying to keep my armor as pristine as possible
ugh I was going to go to the ball in my nice suit
you all ruined it for me
Ow! Talk about accuracy
Wow this--that Imp knew what was going on, too bad he had to die horribly
I actually got to be picking up ammo because I ain't doing it correctly
Am I supposed to get that?
Am I-is it is it QUAD TIME?
OH IT'S QUAD TIME, AIN'T IT?
oh it's so quad time!
QUAD
QUAAD
quawd
These guys aren't dying as fastly as I would like them to quad
QUAD
QUAAAAD
god damn it quawd
QUAAAWD
QUAD
quad
I'm-I'm losing health because I'm just-I'm just getting too caught up in my quad
Man, that was a pathetic quadding
I could've done way better than that, if only I had known
If only I had saved it
Seems like sometimes they want me to pick it up
oh this is where the blood's flowing out of!
oh
oh I thought that was another enemy coming my way
but this is where the blood's flowing out of
but where's the blood flowing into that one?
I'd hate to think that all of hell has a very advanced piping system
their only sewer system is literally blood
but they make sure that every citizen of hell has plenty of supply, no matter what
at all times you can always rely on Blood Incorporated
Okay fine, I'll pick up the blue key
I'm busy on my blood spiel
oh eugh, guarded by a Baron of Hell, kind of
thank you
That sounds good, alright is there anything else here that I should know about?
I seem to have been covering a lot of ground, but there does seem to be a lot more map down there.
I guess I'm going to get to that eventually.
Haven't seen much else in the way of a secret.
buut if it has to be, it has to be
Oop, thank you.
*quietly* oh I haven't used that yet
Alright. Unlocking the blue gate
Opening another portal to hell that's probably going to lead me into death and destruction
That's what I'm here for
uh huh, cool, bank
huh
You know, it makes me curious like who built this stuff
like obviously we're in hell
and there's a lot of pretty advanced construction and piping for the blood and such
that means there's gotta be-there must-there must be,
like some sort, of you know, engineering team
there's-there's gotta be nerds of hell, there's gotta be nerd demons
there's gotta be nerd demons, the engineers
they have to exist-oooh hey
uh, don't do that
could I ask you not to-this weapon sucks ass
I hate it
eh, let me get your butt
don't take any context out of that - ow damn it
nooo just let me have your butt
thank you
well that wasn't exactly-eugh
wasn't exactly what I was looking for, but-where did you go?
where did he go? oh he went invisible
did he go invisible? there's no way that he went invisible
that's not-not possible
not possible-I refuse to belie-oh he fell off
That I could believe- okay let me just do this
boink!
these assho-oh fuck off with you
oh god they're going to get me now cause I lost all my armor
Okay, he's dead, you're not dead
Yeah, just run into a wall, be stupid, and diiiiie
alright he's dead
got it!
just don't-don't Revenant piece of crap ass
whoa what are you doing here? I didn't even see you
I know there's gotta be-hang on I'm gonna just do that real quick
Sorry, let me take that from you, holy shit
alright
no, that's-that's not right
Get that.
I just wanted to get the gas
OWW
geez these guys are kicking my ass all of the sudden
I was just taking names and what have ya
but now I'm just getting my ass handed to me.
huh
where, where, WHERE?
come at me, bro-whoa that's where you is
alright, I--sorry, have no choice, I don't want to take you on normally
that'd be stupid
oh god damn it, not another one
well I saved this up for ya
boink!
What that didn't kill you? Oh I didn't get a direct hit, did I?
NO! Gotcha! Gotcha, bitch
hwabowshki
okay
booyakasha
as I remember that I used to say
Now they're all dead and I am the victor
Therefore I shall, I don't know, do something
eat a bowl of ice cream probably
now where do I go? this way? okay
back towards the collage of death
ooo how lovely, I like the way you replaced
bricks with people, that's my favorite
who's moanin off there?
who's still left alive to moan?
I didn't even know that was possible around here
uh huh I thought I went-oooo it's a new area
me like it, okay!
GERONIMOOO *dissolves into weird noises*
ow, impact compensation is the best probably
is there anything-oh I almost missed a story
me?
Yeah I don't want to be the bearer of bad news even though that's kind of my namesake
but I got out and uh I'm rippin up shit
I'm ripping up every of the shit that you ever built
I mean you're lucky that I don't just break down all your walls
ahh these assholes here
shoot each other, be dicks to each other
kill each other, murder, MURDER
eh they're not murderin
I better do the murdering for them in that case
alright, goodbye
ooo I bet there's going to be secrets abound here
ooo that looks pretty down there, that looks like
I-I might be crazy, but that looks like one of the deathmatch
maps down there, but I-I'm probably just crazy
actually I'm definitely crazy
oooh I love the decorations, always with the skulls and whatnot
*mumbling about secrets*
whoop there wath a thecret
there wath a thecret-ooo
almost missed you, you're half buried in the dirt
found you! thank you
oooh wonder what this guy is
okay
Hep, hup!
get up there
yeah you better not miss out on that one
ah! he wants to kill me, I better kill him first
or was he just waving his arms all being happy?
just trying to defend himself now, but it's not working
boink!
man, you guys used to be touuuugh
they used to be unrelenting amounts of mmmurder in my face
but, alas not anymore-okay
So that is Praetor token-I've got 4 of those and
20 weapon upgrades? Holy shit.
I should do something about that
oh I thought I-wait I
I thought I had that
I had that! eh maybe one of the times when I died
I guess I didn't get that
I don't need that
That'd be stupid to get it at this point, I need something else
aaaaaaaaaaah
I guess this?
Yeah I'd like more quad time, that'd be nice
and I don't even know what I could do with the weapons
because they're pretty much fully upgraded at this point
at least all the ones that I regularly use
ooooh
aaah again with the blood, but that seems to be wasted
man, I wonder how big this place actually is
again, decoration teams did a great job
and how the hell did you get here?
okay some one said that Siege Mode for the Gauss Cannon,
which I can never seem to get ammo for,
but Siege Mode can take down a Baron of Hell in like two shots
so I'm gonna do that
let me see this Siege Mode
oooh me likey
I like that, and you know what since I just got it
and I was just complaining about having all this
"beam now has a devastating area of effect around it"
let's just turn it into a BFG why don't we
"beam charge time is reduced," love that
"Kill 3 or more demons with the Siege Mode beam 10 time--" holy shit
Allows movement while using it if I get that
Well, I'll-oooh
Wha--It seems like they really want me to use this son of a bitch
Does it use-oh it uses the same-ohhh
I didn't know thaaat! If I'd have known that I would've-aww
oh
who you talkin to?
hey buddy, what are you doin?
oh hi, I'll let you do your thing
I hardly ever just get to sit back and enjoy the party
*noises of disgust*
I don't know what's happening and I don't know why they're in fighting
while someone actually talked to me
cause that's new, someone
that voice that I've been hearing about the Doom Slayer
the one that was, you know, talking so much and kissing my ass about how great I am
just heard his voice, so I wonder where he is
eh weird
are you done? God you guys are so inefficient at killing people
eugh just get on with it
GET ON WITH IT
alright, who's left?
oh, er, scuze me, sorry
heeeeh-boink!
ohhhhh
uh
ohhh
D-ohhh....
heeey
owww
I'm a little stunned at my own destructive capacity at this point
wow, like holy shit
that was nuts, that destroyed 'em
good god, why I been--why have I been wasting plasma ammo on that shit, holy crap
who's up there?
you want some of me? heh?
whoa where am I?
where did I go? I don't know
what the hell happened? ahhh so fast
eeeeh boink
boink, thank you
oh no
cmon, let me get a lock god damn it
well that guy's dead
wow lots of Revenants, I don't know why
Lemme get tha--nope, never mind
hello
excuse me
there we go
Hup.  Thank you
get that
Wup!
boink!
mkay
get that...
Awww, I should have glory killed that person, oh well!
whoa what the hell is that?
why do wh--sometimes when they die-wooo hey
I'm going to do this because I found my new favorite toy
*shooting sound with mouth*
oh no, what the hell
you're supposed to-there we go, that's-that's what I wanted, okay
so that was a death from a Mancubus, this is way better than the other one because
ow
ehhh boink
nope
okay
the only problem is that it does stick you to the ground
but I don't know how I'm gonna be able to kill more than one of these bad boys at a time
unless I get some weaker ones to all line up in a straight line
which I don't think they're gonna wanna do
I mean if I was them I wouldn't want to do it
but then again they are very stupid
I didn't need to waste it on that one but
I don't know
hi! you going to let me through now?
aw right when I found BFG ammo
Y'know what, you guys are too kind to me.
You guys are just the nicest -- Okay, nothin' else down there
Off we gooo!
In to wherever other part of hell they want me to go to
After I found my new favorite toy
they're gonna be in very much trouble.
WAIT why was the gate even bother-ohhh is there another gate over here? Alright never mind.
I was just questioning their design, but I shouldn't've questioned the...
...the crack crew of the, uh...
...hell engineering team!
Oh, hey! I got a new toy for you!
A'ight
Walk around the corner!
Hello! Whoaaaa!
Ow, shit.
Wreou!
OH!!
God!!
OHHH
Gohohod!
...Oh hey!
How's it goin'? I got a present for you, too!
Hehhh-boink!
Oh my God, it's sooo destructive!
Ohhh, MAN!
That is amazing!
Aaa-who'din'n- who'da known about that?! I dis- I sure didn't. Good golly.
Well, good thing that I got the two... tough ones outta the way in the beginning.
I didn't even have enough chainsaw ammo to really take care of 'em.
I thought I -- I thought I picked up chainsaw ammo outside, there.
Oh, God, fuck you guys.
Fuck you guys. Where's -- no, that's not what I was...
Shit--
That guy down, okay, he's down...
...down... ohh, fuck. There we go! Okay, we're fine.
We're fiiiine! Thankyou! Alright.
Boink!
whoa god damn it, fuck that
aw fuck that
I hate you guys!
You are the worst, you are literally the worst
ow! Oh shit
oh fuck
aight come at me, bro
come at me
don't even try
don't, I said don't
and you did
I told you not to
and you did anyway
what a dick bag, these guys are assholes
Who'da thought? You walk into the neighborhoods
of hell, and you try to greet everybody, and they just turn out to be dick bags
they actively encourage their dogs to shit on your lawn
and they don't come over to your barbecue, what a bunch of dick holes
okay anyway
now where are we going?
not that
I guess there's only one way to go
besides getting these
okay these guys are testing me in a bit--
and again! This guy! How did he get here?
There's not even like a visual story of
him being here-no that's not him either
like there-like I-i-if this guy's going to be here
what they should've done is told
some sort of story with the environment of how he was here
who he was fighting
like how tough was he? Did he die a bitch?
did he die like a-like a really cool
kind-not as cool as me, I don't want to give him too much credit here
y'know it di-it like
T-tell me the story of what happened to him like
where did he come from, where did he go, where did he come from Cotton Eyed Joe, anyway
gotta take care of these guys, scuze me
stop
oh I'mma get you, I'mma get you
I'mma-oh fuck I didn't got him
god damn it
I was gonna look so cool if I had actually got him
sucks on me for tryna show these guys something, wow
oh shit, he went blind
oh, then he just-man that's sad
there we go, second try
alright got him
Finally
alright who else?
stop!
you're not there!
oh, uh oh uh oh UH OH oh no--
oh shit, oh fuck, well that's not what I wanted to do
I just wanted to show you my cool chainsaw, not actually use it on you
god damn it, stop that
*makes shooting noises with mouth*
I don't have time-oh that's not good
Well, good thing I got this bad boy
whoa that'll stop you in your tracks
whoa shit, that'll s-knock me the hell back
oh shit, WHOA SHIT
that ain't good
whoa shit, oh fuck
NO I di--*sings* I thought there was road there,
♪ I thought there was laaaaand ♪
♪ holy shit I'm a dumbaaass ♪
well
we're gonna ignore that that happened then move on with the rest of our lives
the rest of my life anyway
that shouldn'tve happened, everybody uh please forgive me
okay
trying this again, this time not sucking and dying, that is cool
nope, aaaaaah
oh shit, this guy, whoa, A-hole, A-hole alert
aaaaah fuck
god damn it stop missing 'im, if I could just hit 'im that'd be wonderful
alright
Oh go--WHOA SHIT, ah god damn it
oh am I backed up against a wall? I am aren't I?
well good thing I saved enough, uh bull-- whoa hey
nabout no
how bout no
whoa hahahahaha
alright this guy wants to play
I got just enough for you, buddy
woop nope, I got just enough for the wall apparently
euuuuh
take a gre-nad-ay, don't flame me
uuuuh boing
there we go, got him good
okay that was much better, thank you everybody for cooperating with me
that time was a good exercise
let's just keep doing that that way forever and ever
til we finally-wow
are they preparing me for something? like holy shit
what is that? what are you? euuugh
euuugh what are these things?
why are they here? what do they want? why are there wormies?
eugh gross, alright!
I'm gonna get out my uh-my chain gun here
and we're gonna have a good ol' time, is it the end?
oh!
cool, I've seen that before but what does that-OOOH
aaaah!
interesting
who are you?
welcome! Are you new?
*gasp*
*singsong* it's someone new
ah you were the wormie
ah, yes, you're worm
grooooooss
really gross
ah he's swinging ball hammers
alright then, eh shit that don't look good
huh
oh my god what do-what do I do? He-he seems to have some sort of a shield I'm g-I'm thinking?
*shooting noises with mouth*
okay so I can't get through his shield
but there are opportunities when he's swingin'
so whenever he-whoa that don't look good...whoa
so when he goes on the offensive
which is good for me
cmon, whoa, ah there we go
okay so that did somethin
not a lot, but somethin
hwa-boink! got him
ah that didn't do shit either
cmon give me somethin
ah stop g-stop throwin' a tantrum and give me somethin
stop being such a sissy
come on, whadaya got
woop--nope, okay
eh this guy's easy
if this is all he's got, then this guy's pretty easy
whoa, what are you doin side stepping like a looooser
thank you
missed
Whoa.
okay well that was a tantrum
this guy just seems like he's a-he's a spoiled little brat
that just wants to throw tantrums
oooh hey sorry, didn't mean to talk bad about ya
man, that's his one weakness: antagonization
uh oh is he going into second phaaase?
nope, same shit as before
why change what you don't want to change?
whoa, oh he's spinning in a-oh oh
oh that's a-
that's a cool move, what am I playing World of Warcraft
and you're a raid boss that is gonna do this and I gotta stand out of the fire
is that all I gotta worry about?
oh no he got weak after his thing
whoa shit, oh shit, oh shit
I wasn't ready for that
ya-ya juked me
whoa, I don't know what that is
can I?
oh, oh shit
what the fuck was that?
what the fuck was that? Are you gonna-oh god, don't do that
random bullshit and not tell me what I'm supposed to be doin
god damn it, fuck this asshole
now I gotta do this without getting hit one more time?
is that how it's gonna be? really?
can I just-please? OH COME ON
ahbababubumbubumbumbum
*other random noises*
that's whatcha get
it's whatcha get
I bet you have another phase, dontcha?
do ya? no? oh no, the worm fell over and diiiiied
Hell Guards? Oh god, I-- there's more?
well, I didn't know that, eh shit
huh
well
do they have shields too? are they going to be annoying?
they are, aren't they, oh they're going to be so annoying
oh this is going to be fun
oh maybe they don't have shields, maybe these guys don't have shields
maybe, maybe, but maybe if I were so lucky
whoa, what the frick, stop that
I don't have enough, I blasted away all my fricken BFG ammo on the other guy
and you assholes
are just bein dillweeds about it all
at least you're spittin out a bunch of ammo
which is good for me 'cause I love to do this
hehehe
this... and a little bit of that
and some more of that-oh shit
aaand since you guys aren't putting up much of a defense
alright I guess I'll just toast ya away
aight
it's like hopscotch, just hop and blam and hop and-oh shit whoa-and hop
blam and woah-ow god damn it, good thing I was sitting in a giant pile of health
man if I didn't have that I'd been screwed
eeeh
Oh, that guy is--seems weak.
Huah!
Do you need this??
Do you need this thing on your chest?
In your chest?  Oh, shit, he's dead.
Heh!  He-he blasted his friend, he was like "YOU'RE WEAK."
"HOW DARE YOU GET KILLED BY THIS HU-MAN?"
"If he really is human, I don't really know at this point."
Pldldldleh!
Thank you!  OH HEY!  Aw, aren't you a cutie?
Imma take you outta there.
You seem too hot in there.
Alright.  Weeell.
I don't have a witty remark to say about th--something about stretching before you work out.
I dunno, I was trying to come up with something, I couldn't come up with anything, so...
I apologize for that.
Alright, I did it!
Boink.
I bet you guys thought I was gonna die there, but I'm too cool.
So what do I do about this?  Oh, there we go.
Ah!  Cool!  I got the Keyblade!
What do I do with it?
Well...
I'm not brave enough to use it as a dildo--Hi friends!  You walked in at a weird time...!
Me talkin' about this dildo...!
Uh-huh.  Yes!  Cool!  We're all buddies.
"Tether Activation"?  Oh.
Oh, okay.
G'bye!
Bye, friends!  I guess...
I guess I'm done in Hell!
I didn't do much of that, but at least I got some secrets.
I got the Elite Guards, and the Argent Cell.  Not that they were hiding 'em, but at least I found them nonetheless.
Alright, "VEGA Central Processing."  I'm back...on Mars!  Which is...nice, I suppose.
I dunno where else I would be going.
Oh!  So I'm just coming back so that I can go there again.
"I am VEGA."  What?
You are VEGA?
Why is that the name of the chapter?
Samuel VEGA?  I dunno.
Hey, look at this, I'm back.
Hellooo!
So...
So, what I'm guessing, is that Sa--
Samuel will want to harness the power of the well, while I will want to destroy the well once and for all.  Probably.
That's just the moral...conflict that I imagine is gonna arise from this.
Ohh, this guy's seen better days.
Huh.  I se--I kinda forgot that everyone was still dead over here.
Alright, "VEGA."  I-I know about VEGA.  I get--I get it.  I get VEGA.
I understand.
Is there something that happened over here?
There's nothin' over here, right?
Yeah, nothin' over here.
Alright, le's do dis!
Thank you!
Whaaaat?
Oh, that's not the turn that I expected this to take.
Okay, I have a few questions.
One: We're suddenly in the arctic winter?  Did we go to one of the northern or southern poles of Mars?
Because, it does have poles, the same as Earth does.
Well, not the same, obviously, but...
It does have cold zones, but I didn't know that we were warping all the way over there,
and I didn't know that UA--the UAC also had a facility up there.
Which is awfully confusing, as you could guess.
Is there a way to jump up there?
Nah, that seems like a completely different area.
Prolly something I'm gonna access later, but I'll get to that in a second.
Prolly from in here...
So...either I'm in a tota--whoa, hey!  What are you doin'?
How you doin'??  Awww, where you runnin' away?  He doesn't wanna fight me, I'm-I don't--
Wha--nope!  Yes he does!
Oh... Man.
And, to think.  I was about to let him go.
I was gonna name him and everything.
He was gonna be my buddy.
If one of these guys tried to be my friend, maybe I'd forgive him.
Probably not, but...
Hey...!  You crawlin' down there?
You crawl--oop.  XD I just saw the body just drop out of nowhere.
Welp, looks like I got him.
Got him good.
Alright...what else we got...
*mouth fart*
There was probably... Oh, hey.
Ehhhh, no.
I sa--god dammit, you're a feisty one.
Alright.  There's probably a secret somewhere ar--to do with that.
Yeah, there was!  Ohh, I'm--I'm not gonna lose that.  OH NO!
OHH NOOO!
OHH little guy!!
Awww, little guy.  I-I can go back.
I'll just load the checkpoint.
Unless it checkpointed me at the bottom of this thing!
Which it has done before!
I dunno if it's gonna do that again...
Okay, good!
Okay, so somewhere up here... Sorry.
Somewhere up here there is...a...DOOM guy.
Ahh, he's abo~ve!
OHH.
Ahh--oh, uh, ohhh!  It's back here!  This is worth it, guys, this is worth it.  In my mind, these are worth it.
Okay, so it waaas back here, I just wasn't looking close enough.
Ah, get me up there!  What're you doin'?
What're you doin??  What're you doin' sassy-pants?  Get me up there.
Thank you.
Alright, so, somewhere up here... Or no, down here...there is a way...
Ah, over here!  Huah hueh!  Okay, and I see it here.
Ew.  Hi.
Alright.  Boink!
And then through heeere, down heaaah--Oh!  Hallo!
Hi friend!  Ooh, look at you.  Aren't you looking good--
Oh!  Someone else pointed out that, uh, Keen Guy was from Commander Keen.
Ohh, Quake Guy.  That guy--that guy...That guy!
Quake Guy has seen much better days than that.
Hey, I don't have time to deal with you assholes, I got places to be.
Kabooshki!
I'll leave you with one of these.  Thank you.
Alright.  Anything?  Anything?  Nope.
Uh-huh.
Boink.
Okay!  Let's see!
Huh-booshki!
Ow!  Eh, no, it's alright.
Ooh, Berserk Pack.  I want that when I see some bigger things to Berserk all over.
Alright, I'll get that in a second!
Boink.  Sorry!  Oh.  Is there not another one?
Eh, fine, whatever.  I guess I'll fight them.
Ohh, geez.
Ugh, whatever man.
Just go down.
I don't have time to glory kill up a storm.
Ehh, maybe--maybe a few.  Alright, you know what?  I'm gonna get this.
'Cause they...are just bein' sassy.
Hep!  Time to Berserk!  Ohhh shit!  Oh gohohod!  Oh the destruction!  Someone stop me!
Oh, hey.  How's it goin'?  Boink.  Oh, geez!
Hey!  How's it goin' friend?
Boink!
Let me just--Ohh god!  You didn't need that. Oh, shit.
Oh man.
Ohh, any more?  Anyone else wanna fight?
I go--I-I bought the pow--Oh my God!  This Berserk is lasting a long time.
Does it last longer the more I kill?
Ohhh, that'd be amazing if that's true.
*chuckle* Excuse me!
*giggle*
Anybody up here?
Anybody else?  No?
No one else?  That's it?
Ahhh, c--oh!
Oh, what're you doin' over there?
Little Sassy Sue, clingin' to a wall.
Ahh, wasting all my Berserk.
Alright, open up!
This is the police!
Down here, nevermind.  Sorry, I was in the wrong place anyway.
I coulda pressed this at any moment.
OH, but I didn't!
Alright, there we go.
Cool.  What does that mean?
Apparently no one's gonna tell me, so I gotta find out on my own.
That's an invulnerability sphere...I got maxed out on the BFG ammo now.
Is there any secrets down here?
Doesn't look like it.
Okay, but, up there. I believe I need to go up top now to activate something at a computer terminal,
if I'm not mistaken, over heaah!
And then I'll save the Invulnerability for later.
Boink!
This is just bizarre, having a guy calmly telling me--well, not a guy, an AI calmly tell me how to disable himself.
I mean, that's just a liiittle weird to me.
Eh-heh.
Kay, that guy dead.
Just fall over, please?
Eh...
They take five rockets, not that you guys mind at all.
I just gotta kill them a--whoa!  Oh...
Hey! I thought I heard somethin' over there!
Huh.  Somethin' was sneakin' up behind me.
Super Shotgun!  Boink!  Ah, shit.
Nye-boink!  Ah, shit.
I might as well miss!  God dammit.
There we go.  Head clean off!
Hey, buddy!  You look fancy.
Y'know what else looks fancy?  Whole lotta bullets in the face.
Oh, shit.  Sorry, it overheated.  Lemme get my other, better gun.
Okay.  Welp, where'd your face go?
Boink--ohh, where'd your entire body go?
Alright.  Boink.
Also, someone pointed out that there was a weapon wheel...
A weapon selection wheel that slows down time when you wanna select a weapon.
Which...would be very handy, but...I'm too ingrained on what I've been doing so far,
So I have no idea how to use it.
Alright, everybody--okay, I didn't even need the Invulnerability...
Moving on!
Moving on...
Ok! Are you a tier three fellow?
I dunno if thats true
I dunno if anyone act--
HA I just imagine people just trying to stay calm in the face of, like, demons trying to destroy their shit
that guy's dead
Boink!
Whoa hey Pinky!
Don't.  Just--ah, shit.
AH shit
AH he's coming right for me
oh shit that did nothing
there we go
Oh shit, goddamn it all these tight quarters
There we go
Noo, stop it you
Always way tougher than they need to be
Boink! Oh my God eeuuggh
Shut up dude, no one cares. I'm busy kicking ass
Alright now lets see, where am I supposed to go?
Uuuupp here apparently
Wow, that is... really encouraging. Good motivational speech dude
You're a great help to everybody around
*muttering* I hear someone roaring
Alright, so...
Over this waaay, probably a cooling station that I can des- *Mark is interrupted by monsters*
OH! Hey buddies
Oh fuck off with this guy
ouuhh I should just chainsaw you in the fa-
Whoa hello Pinky, I'll chainsaw you too cause I don't want to be close quarters
Alright, anybody else want to get chainsawed?
Not that I have enough ammo for that, but whatever
Boink
Pistol?
*stroking beard, considering* I wonder if anyone has gone through this entire game with just the pistol
That would be obscenely hard in my mind
Cause I mean even if you are good at dodging, you still can't dodge absolutely everything
...Unless you can
oh OH it was behind me I'm embarrased
*The Mark listens, looking confused*
*He continues to keep the exact same face*
Thank you, why did you need four of you?
A-Are you going to be a final boss?
Huh... Absolute zero huh?
Well, you'd think that as soon as something didn't become absolute zero
it would instantly destabilize because if it was relying on just absolute zero-
holy shit that's- that's some strict parameters to be dealing with.
Cause absolute zero, wow.
If you guys don't know what absolute zero is, it- its the uh..
Theoretically its the lowest temperature that anyone could possibly get to
I'm about to die holy shit I wasn't even paying attention
Talking about absolute zero and shit
Boink!
Ahh wha- uh what?! I'm supposed to be invulnerable when I'm doing that!
There's health on the ground! *shocked Marki face*
What a load of ass! That's bull- I'm supposed to be invulnerable when I do a glory kill
There must have been something like midair
just as I came out of it that was like right next to my face and that's what got me
That's what I get for not paying attention
God I keep getting relaxed like that and I'm just like
"Beh whatever it's just demons, who cares?"
"Who gives a shit?"
Oh I gotta do the thing
Alright
*weird noises* EUUGGH
Okay got it
EH
*confusion* I guess they didn't want to show up
Or they- they're there I ran into something, that was weird
IT'S A GHOST, THEY'VE FINALLY BECOME GHOSTS
OHH NO
Alright that one's done
Uh huh. Cool yeah that's great
Wait where is the other one?
Shut up everybody, I'm thinking
Uh oh, I seem to be in the thick of it
Well, no place I'd rather be
No place like home... Where the fuck is this?
Ohh it's down! Ahh I see
Alright, be right with you everybody
oooHH YOU GUYS ARE DONE. Oh you guys made a horrible error
Oh you made- Hello Baron of Hell!
You also, like everybody else, made terrible
ter- wait - ter- TERRIBLE mistakes
Ohhhh so terrible *giggles evilly*
I found the right power-up
Shhhiiitttt. Holy crap
Hi buddy!
Guh.  What the fuck, did he just fall over and die before I got to him? Of fear?
Oh don't let me swing in the air, I got a Mancubus over here to hit
EUUHH
Wow, that guy blorped
Just get uh- get uh- LET ME PUNCH YOU
LET ME PUNCH YOU! WHAT THE FU- ARE YOU FUCKING KIDDING ME
LET ME- Oh I'm- I'm gonna... Wha FUCK YO-
Oh he just blew up anyway. Fine fuck that guy
Fuck you too
Goddamn it, oh don't make me die
don't- DO NOT
What the- OH fuck off with that shit
EEUUG
How did I lose health so quickly? I don't know
Alright, if I get close to that thing, I'm chainsawing it in the face, I don't care what it says.
Where is it?  Where's that Summoner bastard?
Where's that piece of poop?
Where is he?
Where is he?!
I c--I hear him!  Theere you are!  Stop running away!!
Oh you big baby!!
Oh, you bi--Ohhh you BIG baby!!
YEAH!  I gotcha now!!  WHAT??
WhaaAT?
MAN, am I runnin' into bugs or somethin'??
I am, aren't I?
That's weird, you wouldn't think there would be bugs in a game as polished as this, but oh well.
Scuze me, I gotta pick this up.
I already know about the Cyber-Mancubus.
Okay, where the hell is this last thing??
Sh--and shut up over there!
Kay... fifty.
Ohh, through here, okay, that--alright...
I would've had that like 2 seconds ago, but I didn't because I'm stupid.
Stop.  Just...stop.  Just stop.
You're embarrassing yourself.  Okay.
Whoa!  Hey, how's it goin' there buddy?
You want some-a' me?
Boy, actually, I know--I know better for you.
Alright, he's gonna...Boink!
Okay.  WHY DID THAT NOT STOP YOU!?  Whoooa, okay.
*chuckles* That was sposed to stop you, buddy.
Alright, is there another one around here?
No?
Ehkay!
Cool beans, bruh!  Cool beans!
I dunno where that is, but I'm gonna...follow your instructions to murdalize ya.
What is this?
Thank you, for getting me up 2 feet.  That's amazing.  Good job.  Good job everybody.
ooOOoh!
Down there? Do I need to jump?
I do, don't I?
Weeeeeee--bloink!  Ow.
Okay!
Alright.
I dunno where this is takin' me!
Okay!
Ooh, that doesn't look good.
I'm just gonna pre-emptively blam 'em.
Whooa, two-for-one sale--whoa, shit!
Whoa, wasn't expecting that!
Whoa, fu--stop that!
I'm tryin' to do a thing here!
And that means kill you, just let me-- Oh god dammit, I wasn't...ahhh, fuck.
Fuck you, ya assho'.
You.  Just di--AWWWHH!!
That guy was DEAD! Aww, fuck that.
MmmMMMHHH.
Pulled off a badass two-for-one kill.  Let's just forget that that happened, and then move on with my life.
Forgetting all the awesome that I once imbibed.
Boop!
Bloop.  Bloop.
'Kay.
OH TWO-FOR-ONE AGAIN, I di-- Oh, shit. God dammit, fuck these assholes.
OH fu--WHAT DA FU-- Where the fuck am I?!  OH FUCK OFF!!!
'Kay.  Two-for-one.  Okay.
So...The--I c--I--uhHHHH don't do it again!!  Don't do--Dooon't do it ag--why can't I fucking move???
WHAT THE FUCK IS--I CAN'T M-- WHY?????
WHY CAN'T I MOOOVE??
What the FUCK!??
What was hitting me...THAT I CAN'T MOVE!??
Just still not happy.
Fuck, just...c'mere.  I'm go--I'm gonna getcha.
Oh, ahhh'm gon' getcha!  There we go.
Alright.  And fuck YOU!
...Oh, look, everything else is dead, including me!!
Ffffffffuck THA--TUH!!
Fuck off!  Fuck off!  Fuck OFF--euuh, shit!
Aw, fuck off!  Aw, fuck off--fuck you!  WAAAH!
Ba-boom!  Okay.  Everybody dead?  Everybody nice and dead?  ...Errybody dead?
E'e'ybody dead?  Aww, fuck off!
You and...and f-fuuuck you, I'm out baby!
Okay.  Where am I now?  Where'm I now?  Fuuuck you.
I didn't aim for that one, it wasn't even--he wasn't even there when I locked on.  How did I lock onto that one??
I dunno if I'mma make this!
Wup!  Yes!  Just barely!  Okay, I can finish this off with style!
I mean, not "style."  Obviously, I've--I've been very bad at what I've been doin' here...
But it's not my fault!
Don't flame me.
Just, don't.  What else do I have?
This?  Oh, you're dead?
Aww, come on!  I had--awh, I coulda gotten--well, that woudn'ta really helped me...
Alright.  That was JUST an ORDEAL.
WOWie ZOWie.
My GOD.
Ugh... Then, why did I--why am I still going deeper if all that's happening?
I coulda jus--
Hey, you don't know me!
I just had a fight... It was alright.  Pretty cool--*burp*  Scuze me.  Pardon me.
Okay.  So.  With that being said, I am all outta time for this episode.
Sorry for my poor performance on that last fight,
but hopefully it was funny to you to watch me rage against the machines.
Or the demons... So, thank you again!
And, as always, I will see YOU in the next video!
Bye-bye!  =D
*Haunted outro*
Be careful while watching this series, because it's going to get loud, crude, and offensively rude!
*bink* GOT THAT!  Okay...we're runni--WE'RE RUNNING AWAY NOW!
WE'RE RUNNING AWAY *gibberish*  OH GOD!!